PL.RAMATIINTO
UKRAINIAN CITIZEN,FAOFN TO STOP
VEU N
E TANK STOP, THROWING THEIBICL O
AUTHENTICITY AOF
YOU SEE THAT MAN RIGHT THETRYINP
CNN'S ALEX MARQUKYIV.
ANY E ARHE
CITIZENS, TSSIAIN
RNAEXACTLY WHAT IUGLLCANOT. E
THUS INVN. THAT WA  KYIV, ABOUT
U.VEMIR UKRAE' BIARKIV,
UNDER SOF TH
FORCES.SIA
HES OFETS GOING OUT AND HEADIN
E DIRECTIOOF KHARKIV.T DOESCH UI
THSSIAN INVASION.BEEN A
MIHEAR S AON BY THINIA
FAMIEFFA BEH
ESF AND 60 HAVE BARRED FROM AVU
TO EHEDEFENSO GET MOLOTOV
THEM AT ADVA
THAT IS THEEN ALLINGASPECIHT
S ANLMINN E 0
FORISIDEA'NE
BORD
50%  T  PENTAGON,HEEVE
ARW INSIDEATD THERE HAD EN ATIVA
Y GH HEARING GUNFI  DIRECTION.N.
SO TS FIGHTIASFOR THE  NIGHTS, .
KREMLD ATY
HE OPERAS
AIANIVING DIS THAT OR WANTED TO
NEGOTIATE.
THEN THEY SANEGED ON THAT.
E EY
WE SHOULD NO TE
UKRAINIANS ARE DENYI THAT.
T OULD BOW, THISHE FIGHTI C
OPATA. ANDHE WE RAF
BUILDIAT STRUCTH?teS TH MOST WO
IM
WE'RE TOLDY UKINTHAT SOMEHOW NO
SE BLAME
THRUTHE NS ARWAS A
UKIN.
IY  NT
IS ON A L
E  HAVSAID THEY ARE
NG MILARLA
S.
ANIOWELS
THE FIERCE T ABOUE MILES FROME E
THAT THEY WEREAKINER CLES.VE EXE
THIN THEITY
FR>> OH, MGOODNESSMUCH.
AFE.
>>> AS W SAW WITH
UKMMTHANARURING  NAN
FIGHTING, LIKEMER
>>T'CISIVE MIOVE SINGLE RSON MSN
THE MILLIONS O
ON ST THEY ARE
FIGRESSION WITH VEH RI
LL
I THIN UECTING
TIN'S MISCALCULATION ABO
DEMOTRE NG AGAINST TGGTIMSE WILL
RUSSIALDRSE MOLOTOCOH WEARG PRO
NATION
AND TH
RU PL EUROPEAN AN
SO INKHAT THIS
ER
TO BE AFRA YNGE OPPORTUNIT YOUR.
I THINOUR BESTO R.YOIS IS  FOR .
IFE
DA
>> HATTHOUUS'TLI
BUT IF YOU A
OURADIANFOR THIS
UNATELY, S,E IDEA TO
AND I  D T, TO
OT
EVG , Y UNDERSTAND
.MEE TODY
HE ROFAINE.
I I PROUD TO BE ROTEHEATN.
BLE RET
RM OSHENKO THEREY,ET
AUTHORIZE$350 MILLIONNEW U.S.
LINCE TOKR
FOLLOWININTHS.
THE IS DEMOCRAT
FROM CALIFORNIA AND IS AR
REACTII WONDF I YO
ND HIS R
YMENOIF IT COTO HE ISO
THAT HE MAY GIVE UNCREDIBLY VITE
E FREEDOOF
AND WHEN I WASNI AT  C
HE MAYOR OF A ER
L
FIGHT. AND NF INE, THEE THE WEAT
$350 MILLION IS.
E TOW  RED IN ARSENALFOR THN PEP
SOON, WIBUT IT'S NOT
MITI-TANE  C RUSSIANS.ANTI-AIRC
YOKNOW, YOU HAVE A SITUATION G
SOFTWARE A PICUP RIF